[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Dakota is
in Dallas hi Dakota welcome to the ramsy
show hi Dave thanks for taking my call
how are you better than we deserve
what's up in your
world hey so I am 27 years old I am
making around
$76,000 a year between my full-time job
and a part-time job that I picked up
cool I am fortunate to not have any
credit card debt which is great and I'm
very thankful for that but I am sitting
around $45,000 in debt between my
student loans and a car loan um my
student loans are around 31,000 across
five loans with my highest interest rate
at 6.6% and then my car I have about
14,000 left at a 3.79% interest rate so
I'm sitting around six $6,600 in my
savings account and I followed along
with the show and hearing you know the
goal of having $1,000 in savings is
great however having that little amount
also gives me a lot of anxiety um just
thinking of you know random things that
could come up here and there car breaks
down you know extra expenses things like
that so I guess my question is with my
lowest student loan being around $3,000
technically I do have a savings account
to just start you know knocking that out
right away while still having a little
over 3,000 left in the account so I
guess the question is should I plan to
start drawing from that account to start
knocking those you know student loans
out in the car out paying extra there um
or should I leave that savings account
Alone look at refinancing I'm not sure
how deeply are you willing to cut your
lifestyle and how many hours are you
willing to work to where you could do
this in one
year yeah so 46 what did you say 40
41,000 right 45,000 about
45,000
76,000 out of 76,000 means you live on
mhm uh or you live on a little bit more
but you pay off everything in one
year yeah I'm really I I'm working about
40 to 50 hours for my full-time job
salaried position um and then my
part-time job I was pulling an extra
like 15 to 20 hours a week there um at a
retail gig um for my mental health
having that much time working why does
it hurt your mental health to work
um just between the responsibilities
it's not that I don't have the mental
health or the capacity to work I don't
want to come across like that you said
for my mental health that's a bunch of
crap yeah it was just to the point where
I was feeling super overwhelmed with the
amount of hours I was putting in I
wasn't yes because you did not have a
you you did not you felt like a rat in a
wheel the you were not getting traction
if you were seeing this debt drop off at
$3 to $4,000 a month and you knew you
were going to be done a year you'd be
fine working but you were just stuck
working yeah I I did that's yeah that's
a good that's a better way of putting it
I felt really stuck I felt like I was
getting all this extra money and then it
try working all the time really hard if
you got great traction is not that
harsh right it's not what you want to do
the rest of your life but I want you to
be done in a year in that case
$1,000 as an emergency fund is not as
scary because you're going to be done in
a
year mhm oh was wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute you
have almost $6,000 now right yeah I've
got about $6,600 in my savings account
oh so we're gonna put 6,000 on the 45
now we've only got 39 to do in a
year
wow so I guess to get further
clarification so the 1,000 like I said
does give me a little bit of anxiety
because I just think I want you to have
a little bit of anxiety what's giving
you anxiety is
$45,000 debt hanging over feeling stuck
when you are knocking off $3 to $4,000
you're not going to have anxiety you're
going be knocking it out and then you're
G to be done you're going to be 28 years
old and not have a payment in the world
can you breathe that in I know and what
is your recommendation because I think
that is my recommendation
darling well I had to replace two tires
on my car so I think if I would have
only had $1,000 in my that's enough to
replace two tires and then you replenish
it so you the debt snowball let's say
that you have another two tires go out
pause the debt snowball your next
paycheck's going to cover the tire you
already have a th000 in the emergency
fund and then you move on you just pick
up where you left off get the thousand
bucks back instead of 3,000 or 4,000
going on your debt this month only 2,000
does because you got to buy some
tires okay that makes more sense okay
you got two new tires now so that that
problem's out of your way yeah it'll be
something else though there'll be
something else
break right and you're gonna be working
all the time
well you won't have time to spend
money right and don't worry just before
you die you'll pass
out yeah but hey I I'll pass out and be
de free
exactly I'm kidding with you kiddo but
listen if you the the trick is this we
have figured out that the more intense
people are the math almost quits working
you get out so fast because you create
this emotional spiritual momentum that
goes with a math momentum and it becomes
all-encompassing I mean you become like
like you joined a cult or something for
a short period of time right you don't
think about anything else for a short
period of time and then you're going to
be 28 years old and not have a payment
in the world and you've been playing
footsie with this stuff for almost a
decade it's been hanging around like a
problem talk about anxiety
inducing yeah and I I am wanting to get
all of this taken care of you know my
boyfriend and I are both individually
trying to take care of our debt before
we decide to take that next step of
getting married and starting a family
and things like that so you don't have
to wait to get out of debt to be married
you just both have to you both have to
be in agreement that we're goingon to
get out of debt that's all yeah that is
true that is true I'm I'm ready to get
it knocked out though do it do it do it
Go Dakota Dakota Dakota I dare you to
take 5600 and attack some debt today
you're going to get a little pep in your
step so hey
Samantha was just on here doing her debt
free scream she made $70,000 when she
started she paid off 57,000 in 27
months and finished her master's
degree cash flowed all kinds of expens
that right before you just a minute ago
single your age just a minute ago go
back and watch her that free scream just
a minute ago see you you can absolutely
do this you can absolutely so get it it
Dakota Dakota Dakota we're cheering you
on hey we're going to put you in
Financial Peace University and pay for
it we're going to put you in every
dollar premium so you can hook up and
run your budget and I want you to just
go crazy for a short period of time so
you get your life back and you you do
that Dakota you will never go back in
debt and you will become wealthy because
you will pay attention to money and make
it behave the rest of your life money is
a fabulous slave it is a horrible
master and it has been owning your butt
for a decade it's time you got on top of
it and you own it Dakota Dakota Dakota
she could do it George yeah I just keep
thinking about this Mental Health crisis
in America and I think it has more to do
with debt than a $1 thousand emergency
fund we're feeling out of control when
when when you're doing stupid stuff or
you're or you're don't have a sense of
Destiny everything is anxiety inducing I
mean stupid should induce anxiety they
have a direct you should you should have
anxiety if you're doing stupid stuff
shouldn't you that's your body telling
you this is not smart that's yeah that's
like you're not really should be anxiety
inducing she's not doing stupid but I'm
just saying the but I'm just in general
you know and working and not knowing
where you're going like she was talking
about that that is that does do that but
hard work does not cause mental health
problems never has as a matter of fact
it solves a lot of them actually talk to
Dr John delone I was talking about with
him on the air the other day about this
one of the things that they tell people
uh that that are struggling with
depression is get
outside vitamin D and in engage in
physical
activity and get engaged in something
where you're seeing
traction all of those sound like work to
me so yeah work your butt off go crazy
for a short period of time and you know
work is not anxiety inducing ever well
it is if you're working for a toxic jerk
I take that back but yeah but I guess
but I mean just the essence of work
itself is not anxiety inducing yeah so
very cool Dakota Dakota Dakota create
your free every dooll budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life